what about consciousness
the c word do what do you think that's
fundamental
to solving agi or is it a quirk of human
cognition
so i think most of the arguments about
consciousness don't have a whole lot of
merit uh i think that consciousness is
kind of
the way the brain feels when it's
operating
yes and this idea that you know i do
generally subscribe to sort of the
pandemonium theories of consciousness
where there's all these things bubbling
around and i think of them as kind of
slightly randomized sparse distributed
memory bit strings of things that are
kind of happening recalling different
associative memories and eventually you
get some level of consensus and it
bubbles up to the point of being a
conscious thought there and the little
bits of stochasticity that are sitting
on in i in this as it cycles between
different things and recalls different
memory that's largely our imagination
and creativity um so i don't think
there's anything deeply magical about it
certainly not symbolic i think it is
generally the flow of these uh
associations drawn up with static
stochastic noise overlaid on top of them
i think so much of that is like it
depends on what you happen to have in
your field of view as some other thought
was occurring to you that overlay and
blend into the next key that queries
your memory for things and that kind of
determines how you know how your chain
of consciousness goes so that's kind of
the qualia the subjective experience of
it is not
is not essential for intelligence i
think so i don't think there's anything
really important there
what about some other human qualities
like fear of mortality and stuff like
that like um the fact that this ride
ends
is that
is that important like you you me you
know we talk so much about this
conversation about the value of
deadlines and constraints
um do you think that's important for
intelligence actually a super
interesting angle that uh that i don't
usually take on that about has death
being a deadline that forces you to make
better decisions because i have heard
people talk about how if you have
immortality people are going to stop
stop trying and working on things
because they've got all the time in the
world
i am but i would say that
i don't expect it to be a super critical
thing that uh that a sense of mortality
and death impending death is necessary
there because those are things that they
do wind up providing reward signals to
us and we will be in control of the
reward signals and there there will have
to be something fundamental that causes
that engenders curiosity and goal
setting and all of that i am something
is going to play in there at the reward
level
i am you know whether it's positive or
negative or both
i don't have any strong opinions on
exactly what it's going to be uh but
that's that type of thing where
i doubt
that might be one of those half dozen
key things that has to be sorted out on
exactly what the master reward that's
the meta reward over all of the uh the
local task specific rewards have to be
that could be that big negative reward
of death
maybe not death but ability to walk away
from an interaction so
it bothers me when people treat ai
systems like servants
so it doesn't bother me but i mean it
it's it really is drawing the line
between what an ais system could be it's
limiting the possibility of an asset
could be is treating them as justice
tools now that's of course for from a
narrow ai perspective there's so many
uh problems that narrow ai could solve
just like you said
as
in in its form of a tool but it could
also be a being
which is much more than a tool and to be
a to become a being you have to respect
that thing for being a being and for
that it has to be able to have
to make his own decisions to walk away
to say i had enough of you i would like
to break up with you now
uh you've not treated me well and i
would like to move on so
i think that actually that choice
to end things
so i i
couple things on that so on the one hand
uh it is kind of disturbing when you see
people being like people that are mean
to robots and you know mean to alexa
whatever and that seems to speak badly
about humanity but there's also the
exact opposite side of that where you
have so many people that imbue humanity
in inanimate objects or things that are
toys or that are are relatively limited
so i think there may even be more more
danger about people putting more
emotional investment into a lot of these
proto-ais in different ways yeah um and
then the ai would manipulate that
but as far as like the ai ethnic sides
of things
i
really stay away from any of those
discussions or even really thinking
about it it's similar with the safety
things where i think it's just premature
and there's a certain class of people
that enjoy thinking about
impractical things things are not in the
world and
you know of pragmatic effect around you
and i think that
begin again because i don't think
there's going to be a fast take off i
think we actually will have time to have
these debates when we know the shape of
what we're debating
and some people do take a principled
approach that they think it's going to
go too fast that you really do need to
get ahead of it that you need to be
thinking about this because we have slow
processes of coming to any kind of
consensuses or even coming up with ideas
about this
and
maybe that's i maybe that's true
i wouldn't put any of my money or
funding into something like that because
i don't think it's a problem yet and i
think that we will have these signs of
life when when we've got our learning
disabled toddler we should really start
talking about some of the safety and
ethics issues but probably not before
then can you elaborate briefly about why
you don't think there'll be a fast take
off
is there some deep intuition you have
about it does it because it's grounded
in the physical world or why yeah so
it is my belief that we're going to
start off with something that requires
thousands of gpus and
i i don't know if you've tried to go get
a thousand gpu instance on a cloud
anytime recently but these are not
things that you can just go spin up
hundreds of i
there are real challenges to i mean
these things are going to take data
centers and data centers take years to
build you know and the last few years
we've seen a few of them kind of coming
up going in different places their big
engineering efforts you can hear people
bemoan about the fact that i you know oh
the the network was wired all wrong and
it took them a month to go unwire it and
rewire it the right way these aren't
things that you can just magic into
existence
and the ideas of i like the old tropes
about it's going to escape onto the
internet and take over other systems
there's the fast takeoff ones are
clearly nonsense because you just can't
open tcp connections above a certain
rate no matter how smart you are even if
you have perfect hacking ability that
take over the world in an instant sort
of thing just isn't plausible at all and
even if you had access to all of the
resources these are going to be
specialized systems where you're going
to wind up with something that is
architected around exactly this chip
with this interconnect and it's not just
going to be able to be plopped somewhere
else now interestingly it is going to be
something that the entire
um
the entire code for all of it will
easily fit on a thumb drive that's total
spy movie thriller sorts of things where
you could have hey we crack the secret
agi and it fits on this thumb drive and
anyone could steal it now they're still
gonna have to build the right data
center to deploy it and have the right
kind of life experience curriculum to
take it up to the point where it's
valuable but the real core of it the the
magic that's gonna happen there is going
to be very small you know it's again
tens of thousands of lines of code not
millions of lines of code it is possible
to imagine a world as you mentioned in
the spy thriller
view if it's
if it's just a few lines of code
we can imagine a world where the surface
of computation is growing maybe growing
exponentially
meaning
there's you know the
the refrigerators start getting a gpu
and uh just
every first of all the smartphones the
billions of smartphones but maybe if
there
become
highways through which code can spread
across the entirety of the computation
surface
then you don't any longer have to book
aws
um
gpus there's real fundamental issues
there when you start getting down to
taking an actual problem and putting it
on an abstract machine like that
that has not worked out well in practice
and the idea that
there was always
like it's always been easy to come up
with ways to get com compute faster to
say more flops or more uh more gigaops
or whatever there that's usually the
easy part but you then have interconnect
and then memory for what goes into it
and when you talk about saying well cell
phones well you're limited to like a 5g
connection or something on that and if
you say how
if you take your your calculation and
you factor it across
a million cell phones instead of a
thousand gpus in a warehouse you might
be able to have some kind of a substrate
like that but it could be operating then
at 1 1000 the speed and so yes you could
get you could have an agi working there
but it wouldn't be a real-time agi it
would be something that is operating at
really a snail's pace you know much much
slower than kind of human level thought
for things yeah i'm not worried about
that problem you're transferring the
problem into the interconnect the
communication the shared memory
the the the collective intelligence
aspect of it which is extremely
difficult as well i mean it's back to
the very earliest days of super
computers you still have the the balance
between bandwidth storage and
computation and sometimes they're easier
to get one or the other but it's been
remarkably constant across all those
years that you still need all three
you